um our first on today's twitter
questionnaire comes from at
david kovucci i think um
everyone is talking about good
quarantine habits tell me your worst
i for one have started chewing nicotine
gum for no reason
other than it was on sale at the
pharmacy
i want your life david because obviously
not a lot is going on
and i'm very busy um i don't know what's
your court what's your worst quarantine
habit
seth um i don't know i think i'm over
flossing
uh just to like break up the day
you know what i'm doing q-tips i already
make youtube queen i love cleaning my
ears i can't stand
i can't stand like any kind of moisture
in my ears and i've been showering a lot
because we live on a ranch
and i i i'm probably going to run my
ears
somehow i look i love a good q-tip but i
like to savor it i don't
when i feel like overusing a q-tip takes
away the excitement for me it's a treat
it's like you know if i if i accomplish
something
then i'm like you've earned yourself a
cute tip yeah i do there i love cleaning
up my ears
okay can i ask you a q-tip question do
you
did you do one q-tip that you switch for
each ear or does each ear get one q-tip
here's the weird thing about me it's so
interesting you asked
um i do one q-tip and i do one side and
then i do the other side deepen
and then i take another q-tip and i do
the at like a round
you know inside here yeah yeah same
thing with the other side
i swear yeah it's a process
i enjoy q-tips i call them ear-gasms
they're good we might want to not put
that in the show
um or i don't know he'll put it in um
all right the next one is from at hello
cullen
um what if seinfeld met the sopranos
that's actually great just like what
what happened
yeah like what do you so said what do
you think turf for like i'm just saying
like
i think like jerry would be like what's
the deal with paulie walnuts
why is this out of his hair i think it
would be more interesting to see kramer
with them anyway
i love science definitely like sort of
like a blow up the mob
game somehow yes it would have been a
great episode
um good question um okay this next one
is from
jay portney who asks what's the dumbest
fight you've gotten into in quarantine
well you know what here's the thing you
should never ask a married person
right yeah i don't even know like
brandon and i i
it's just because it's every the kids
are crazy everything's crazy and all
we're all together i mean are you you
and your wife
have you all just yeah stupid things
where i was doing well my um
uh our two-year-old like uh he like fell
and hit his
he hit his uh chin and you know he split
it open
and i immediately panicked because i
thought we were gonna have to go to the
emergency room which is obviously not a
place you want to be right now
you know because you don't want to
require the attention of first
responders who are dealing with more
important things um
and basically while i was flipping out
and screaming about how bad it was my
wife just like put a band-aid on it and
fixed it
became very clear that i'm not the
person you want in a crisis
okay i'm you and my husband is her um i
would have been like oh my god
i can't even there's not even we've had
so many dumb arguments like stupid and
then we
and then literally in the moment we're
like this is so stupid like let's just
go have a drink
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going